foreign
to raise funds for the catastrophic
earthquake that's taking place in turkey
and Syria please donate whatever you can
even if it's one pound to save the
people's lives inshallah assalamu
alaikum brothers and sisters and dear
friends you all know what's going on in
turkey and Syria with the massive
earthquake
earthquake and many people are in
despair many many people are homeless
many people have lost their lives and
even their kids some videos are
disturbing to watch brothers and sisters
this is a video
of a young boy under the rubble let's
watch this for ourselves brother and
sisters
[Music]
Italian
says what you saw there he's under the
rubble and you can hear people screaming
and he says I don't know if I will come
out alive
brothers and sisters do you know what
that reminded me of what Allah brothers
and sisters just imagine being under the
rubble yes imagine brothers and sisters
when we enter our Graves we are also
going to be under some sort of rubber
brothers and sisters we're going to be
underneath the Earth and while the
screams that he was hearing is of the
Muslims of the Believers who were
shouting for help but brothers and
sisters will lie not their screams but
what it's made me remember brothers and
sisters subhanallah is the prophet peace
be upon him said if Allah was to enable
for you guys to hear what the punishment
the the punishment the grave of the
people that are going through you I fear
that you will not bury your debt
even though subhanallah these are people
who are asking for help they're innocent
people under this Rubble but brothers
and sisters two things imagine when you
enter the grave and number two brothers
and sisters you may be hearing the
screams of others in the barzak who are
being punished why brothers and sisters
well lie if this is not a wake-up call
the prophet peace be upon him said save
yourself from the fire
do you know how humongous the fire is
just imagine how humongous it is that
the Hadith or the prophet peace be upon
Him says that the fire will say is there
not more
and the prophet peace be upon Him is
saying save yourself from the humongous
Raging Fire
even if you give half a date in charity
do you know what that symbolizes that
means you may have it each and half part
of the day and give half of it in
charity
imagine how merciful Allah is brothers
and sisters this is where they need us
the most please for the sake of Allah
give what you can and support your
brothers and sisters in turkey and Syria
with one ummah which I'm trying to raise
funds for assalamualaikum